parler de discrimination discrimination
au travail mais liée au physique cette
fois ci on en parle peu mais elle serait
assez répandue et pour illustrer ce
fléau les journalistes de m6 tories ont
engagé une comédienne
il nous fait passer un test dans bausch
à deux occasions une foi en la sublimant
la rendant plus joli avec un joli
maquillage une belle coiffure des jolis
vêtements et puis une autre fois en la
rendant moins un zoli en wallonie sans
les dents avec des vêtements un peu
moins moins élégant regardez le résultat
emilie et joséphine sont convoqués à des
entretiens d'embauché
je sais comment faire pour m'organiser
c'est quelque chose que j'aime bien ce
qu'ils peuvent pour d'autres personnes
paraître un peu particulier une
candidate organisé volontaire et qui
parle anglais couramment
après un entretien express de 19 minutes
notre comédienne et raccompagnés vers la
sortie
le patron va-t-il privilégier le
physique de joséphine qui a moins
d'expérience ou le parcours
professionnel de la brillante emilie au
physique plus ingrat je pas bilingue 1
je préfère prévenir le recruteur ne
réagit pas vraiment à cette lacune
cette fois il s'attarde sur la partie la
plus personnelle du cv de joséphine
deux jours plus tard joséphine reçoit la
confirmation de son embauche
emilie elle n'aura jamais de nouvelles
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de cette
histoire comme par hasard c'est la jeune
fille qui est un peu plus avenante alors
oui la même on est d'accord au téléphone
voilà c est la jeune femme qui a été
mise en valeur avec pourtant acv qui
était moins intéressant qui a eu le job
est ce que vous comprenez ce que vous
dites après tout il fait aussi un tout
c'est peut-être que dans le job il y
avait une fois une fonction d'accueil et
que voilà
ou au contraire vous dit non ce n'est
absolument pas excusable ludivine non ce
n'est pas excusable d'autant que c'est
la deuxième si vous voulez c'est le
deuxième critère de discrimination à
l'embauché
après des critères ethniques mais ce
sont des critères physiques et il ya
deux catégories dont deux femmes et
hommes qui sont visés les femmes à forte
corpulence et les hommes qui sont petits
qui sont d'hommes bardot fils un petit
peu mais un petit peu les est ce qui est
assez insidieux c'est que
même le patron lui-même ne se rend pas
compte en fait qu'ils facturent
discriminés parce que quand on le
rappelle après dans le sujet en lui
expliquant ce qu'il vient de se passer
il dit bah écoutez hausse énorme alors
c'est normal cette fois je me suis pas
vraiment rendu compte mais savez c'est
un tout j'ai vu une fille plutôt
sympathique et je me suis dit que
c'était mieux de l'abs avril quelques
uns avec les autres via lors ça dépend
réellement de la fonction sauf si le
soldat est un mauvais recruteur ça
dépend de la fonction si même si si la
fonte dans la fonction de représentation
de présentation le physique intervient
on peut comprendre qu'ils choisissent
quelqu'un c'est chacun mais c'est une
réalité
donc on peut comprendre par contre à
performances égales si vraiment il
choisit une personne uniquement ses
droits pour tous notamment il faut
savoir parler anglais est là il y en a
une celle qui est soi-disant joly eh ben
elle parle moins bien on n'est que
l'autre est le facteur va perdurer
employeurs parce qu'il doit prendre en
perdant en principe celle qui remplit le
mieux la fonction
et là il s'est fait déformée par des
sentiments personnels il à parts égales
et visiblement pas vraiment conscience
c'est qu'ils font c'est à dire qu'on est
un peu conditionné thibault qu'est ce
que vous en pensez à arrêter d'avoir des
oeillères sur la société qui nous
entoure au début jean michel avait
raison et puis il a dévié on ne connaît
pas exactement le poste si ça se trouve
c'est vraiment un poste central
il faut être en effet avenante il faut
être au contact enfin viande pardonnez
moi c'est parce que vous auriez aux 10
kilos en trop vous avez vous êtes c'est
dramatique mais c'est une réalité nous
entourent c'est qu'il ya des ondes entre
les personnes ayant un relationnel
subjectif qui se met et si la personne a
mieux accrochée avec la seconde personne
qui s'est présentée la société exemple
un poste d'accueil vous ne mettez que
des jeunes femmes qui font à 38 et qui
sont aujourd'hui je dis la vérité milite
pas homme parce que là quand vous dites
jeune femme déjà c'est discriminant ça
aurait pu être une femme qui renaît là
on a réussi à transposer sur ce poste et
la wii puis c'est pas parce que c'est la
réalité bonne société qu'on doit rien
faire et dit robert laissons les choses
comme ça il ya une autre discrimination
à l'envers c'est pour les belles
personnes ça veut dire une femme très
belle oui aura beaucoup de mal à avoir
des hautes qualifications c'est vrai
j'en ai chalamov arsenal parce qu'en
fait les gens considèrent qu'une femme
belle et forcément complètement teubé
alors qu'elle inverse un homme très beau
il se dira plus haut dans la société à
parce que on imagine que il est paré de
toutes les
ça on se dit qu'il n'a plus confiance en
lui et qu'il inspire plus confiance aux
gens donc donc il faut pas être ni trop
belle ni pas examiner si cet avis est
donné et les moches gagnant moyen entre
11 et 13% de moins que les autres
personnes donc sa manière incroyable on
en cause pour cent d'entre eux 11 et 13%
de moins qu'un jeune femme les autres
que l'incroyable autre dans le même s'il
m'est arrivé quelque chose il ya
quelques années dans le monde du travail
de particuliers mais qui ressemble à ça
c'est à dire qu'on était dans un service
de quatre hommes mon rédacteur en chef
fait pas c'est donc un entretien a eu à
plusieurs jeunes femmes ou hommes
stagiaire et un niveau équivalent il se
rend compte qu'il y a deux femmes et
notamment une qui était plus qu'à venant
très sexy et il ne l'a pas prise parce
que finalement il s'est dit mais elle va
ça va être une bombe à retardement au
sein du service
quatre hommes à épouser capable de ce
travail avec les mecs je sais pas trop
comment le prendre c'est intéressant ce
que vous dites sur le monde du travail
quand même les discriminations au
physique au travail j'y crois ou je n'y
crois pas on vous a posé la question est
évidemment de façon en finale vers mende
le voit malheureusement 92% d'entre vous
y croyez il y en a qui sont victimes de
discrimination et puis d'autres qui
s'auto discrimine regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
compliqué après